lost in America is sherwin Newlands new
memoir of his father the National Book
Award winner recounts his Bronx
childhood in a yiddish-speaking
household and it's aftermath during this
talk from rj julia booksellers in
Madison Connecticut this is an hour
good afternoon it is an honor for me to
be able to introduce dr. neuland to all
of you this afternoon as I'm sure many
of you know how we'd I won a National
Book Award but it did something else
that lost in America has done as well
and that is it changes the conversation
and I was particularly struck by it just
before I came here I learned that a good
friend who had been dying died and i
realized how much dr. Nolan has changed
the conversation where we have a better
understanding cope with it in a
different way and that is a gift that
not many have and what he's done in lost
of in America is that again I had spoken
with Shep and Cynthia ozik and I shared
this quality is the only quality we
share well we're both from New York for
both Jewish but other than that and that
is that we read the book through the
night once we started it because you
just couldn't put it down and what it
did it's about Shep's Jewish father but
it's about the experience of being an
immigrant and it's about the things that
we need to confront in ourselves that we
do and don't do in dealing with all of
that I remember as a child of immigrants
just wanting to be regular just wanting
a parent who spoke English and didn't
make my clothes so I could go to the
store and buy store-bought clothes and
Shep has done this in a way that I think
is brilliant and i think is brave and i
think will again change the way we have
conversation and we are lucky that we
have dr. neuland here today to talk with
us about it and this book I feel
confident we'll go
to win even more awards and accolades
then how we die and Shep just continues
to go on to I was going to say astound
but astound would mean we were surprised
which were not he will continue to go on
to write and share his experiences with
us in a way that will linger with us for
a long time so please join me in
welcoming dr. Shep Shep Sherwin nua well
this is this is wonderful thanks an
awful lot Roxanne you know I was
flattered enough to be invited to come
and speak here and I was even more
flattered when I walked in and I heard
that Roxanne was going to introduce me
herself but after hearing that I it's
going to be worse than ever my wife is
very fond of saying you know you think
that everybody else is an extra in the
major motion picture of your life well
after today it could be insufferable
this this book makes me think of that
old aphorism that you can't tell a book
by it's cover because this cover tells
the whole story of the book in fact it
was done by a fellow named chip kid who
had read the book and he's one of the
cover artists at random house had read
the book and asked to do the cover and I
had not wanted any pictures of my family
in the book and the reason is simply
that like everybody here I was a big
reader of fiction when I was a kid and
still am somewhat and always like to
have in my mind an image of the people
the dramatis personae and I don't like
to have that tampered with and I had
just read that wonderful book of oliver
sacks is uncle tungsten where I had once
again gotten everybody straight in my
mind got to the middle of the book and
they're all these photographs which
changes from me so I said no photographs
but chip said look if I'm going to do
this cover and I want to do this cover
you've got to send me a bunch of
pictures so I took out all the pictures
from the basement where they hadn't been
seen in a long time and I ship them off
to Knopf to Random House and I waited
about six weeks and they send me the
sample cover and I just couldn't believe
it I called him up and I said you know
no one's going to buy my book
everything's right on the cover and what
do you see this is the day I graduated
from Medical School in 1955 and it was
taken outside of the building that
serves as a dormitory for medical
students and there are these two men and
although their father and son they look
so different from each other one of them
is screwing up his face because the
light is too much for him he seems
somewhat distracted he's 66 years old in
this picture the other is 24 years old
and he's smiling and his life is in
front of him and he's optimistic and
he's happy but that's not the quality
that appealed to me so much about this
what appealed to me so much is the way
he has separated these two men even
found a picture in which they're looking
in two different directions but he's
also brought them together so he
separated them by the title but the
title also brings them together and of
course that was among the major
motivations for me to write this book
because I couldn't figure out ever
whether I was together with my father or
separated from my father whether I
wanted to be with my father or I wanted
to be away from my father whether I
loved him or whether I hated him not
that those two things are inconsistent
but that became of course the journey
that I took trying to find out how I
felt about him I've never been able to
understand anything unless I wrote about
it when I wrote how we'd I wrote this
whole big long book and it went into
galleys as it always does and they send
you the galleys back and forth and they
have what's called the first pass and
the second pass and then there's the
bound galleys and each time you read it
looking for mistakes but I had never
really read the book and a week before
publication my editor called me said you
know Shep's better read your book
and I thought that was kind of silly he
was about thirty six or seven at the
time and you know how old I was in 1994
pretty old already so I said why I've
just gone through the gallery she said
you don't understand it's different when
you sit down and read a real book so I
sat down he took me a week I could only
read a chapter at a time cuz i would get
so emotional and i was astonished by it
because i had written that book as i
write all of my books without any
forethought you know i take a number two
two and a half now eberhard faber pencil
it's like a computer it's got software
on the n dogface good stuff and I just
write on these large white pads that at
that time you could only get at the
annual meeting of the yale china
association had a particular kind of
line system and i would i stayed on the
Medical Board of the Ale china
association for six years so that I
could collect these things and then
finally they started selling them at
staples about four years ago so I don't
have to go to China every year anymore
in any event so I had written this book
really completely free associating
without thinking about what I was doing
and I knew it had a beginning in the
middle and an end but when I sat down
and read it and not in galleys but in a
real book I was astonished by it there
was a philosophy of death and dying in
this book that had been subliminal in my
mind but was graphically explained in
the book there were so many other things
that I'd only half understood that we're
there for me in that book and it was
quite an astonishing experience as I say
and writing that book taught me a number
of things about writing in general
because I you know I've never taken a
writing course I've never really spoken
to a writer about how she or he does
this thing I'm just sat down and done it
one of the things that taught me of
course was that you don't write a book
out of your conscious mind you write it
out of
deep place which the Greeks of course
called the muse sitting over your head
but it's not sitting over your head is
deeply within your head and it's there
and you don't know it's there and you
shouldn't fiddle with it it manifests
itself in positive ways of manifests
itself in negative ways when this book
how he died had been published someone
called me who didn't know me very well
and said where's your father in this
book and I was just taken aback because
I was wrestling with the ghost of my
father then as I still am somewhat
wrestling with the ghost of my father my
grandmother was in how he died every
member of my family was in how he died
and this powerful authoritative figure
that permeated every moment of my
existence wasn't in the book and I had
never even thought about it during the
year that it took to write it and it was
then and there that I decided he needs a
book he needs a book not because he
needs a book but because I need a book
why isn't he in this book why didn't I
do that but more importantly as I said
earlier how do I feel a bit got it was
grave once a year I stand there and
think about him my older son who's now
38 frequently comes with me stands there
with me we talk about him and yet I'm
not sure how I feel about him so this
seemed an opportunity to find out what i
thought just as with how we die i found
out how i thought about life and death i
could find out about my father so how to
approach it first let me tell you that
my publisher is the Alfred a Knopf
company blessed their multitude of souls
weren't the least bit interested in my
writing this book and they said to me
things like well you know there are too
many memoirs besides you've got a genre
this notion of explaining medical things
to laypeople there's a kind of book
people expect from you and it's not a
memoir
and then one person actually said who
will care who won't care about such a
book well finally my editor dan Frank by
then about 38 years old became convinced
that maybe this is a worthwhile project
and from time to time he and I would
talk about it and he would help me mold
what my thoughts were but once again how
do you really do such a thing how do you
bring to focus what you think and what
you don't know you think about your
father well let me tell you the lesson I
learned from writing how we die those of
you who've read it will remember that
there is a 2 chapter section on old age
which is to me the epitome of the dying
process and since I do right by free
association I had written the first two
paragraphs of that chapter and suddenly
it occurred to me that I had spent the
first 18 years of my life watching
someone slowly die of old age and I
thought I wanted to use that someone my
grandmother as the example of dying in
that way and I walked into the kitchen
my wife wasn't working that day and I
said you know I really want to write
about my bubba as we called her in
Yiddish but who will care who will care
about a four foot ten inch Jewish
grandmother couldn't speak a word of
English who never went out of the house
except on the holidays when she
gradually made it to the synagogue
because the two of us boys took her
answer looked up at me and she said the
three words that change the book and
essentially changed the way I wrote she
said don't censor yourself just write
what comes into your mind if you want to
write a better write about her and if
your attitudes don't like it you can be
very sure they will tell you and you can
take that out of the book if you think
you need to or
too so I sat down and some of you will
remember how intimate those details were
I talked about the three of us my
grandmother my aunt and I sleeping
actually in the same bed for several
years when I was young of course they
had no effect on my psychosexual
development at all as you can imagine
and me waking up many nights she used to
keep a Maxwell House coffee can under
the bed because she couldn't make it to
the bathroom you know she died at 96 so
we're talking about a woman over the age
of 90 and she would separate her legs
and crouch down a little bit urinate
into that Maxwell House coffee can I
talk about that in the book because I'm
talking about the kinds of things that
happen to us as we lose our powers I had
set to Sarah you know if I write about
those things what's going to happen I'm
gonna end up with six readers and
they're all going to be aging Jewish
boys from the Bronx well you know I
wrote that book and I got thousands of
letters and I kept every letter and I'm
a compulsive surgeon so I answered about
99% of them and the only reason I didn't
answer the others was they got lost or I
couldn't find them on a particular day
when I was writing and guess what the
most common topic of all of those
letters was my grandmother why because
everybody has a grandmother that they
love if they're lucky enough that their
grandmother was still near them they
felt about their grandmother just as I
felt about my grandmother and people
kept writing to me about it my favorite
letter which I actually brought with me
because i xeroxed it and knowing that I
was going to come here and knowing that
Roxanne would appreciate this I thought
I'd read a bit of it came from a fellow
named jim barnes who wrote early in this
four or five page handwritten letter
that can you hear me back there you
can't good that he had been a lawyer in
Florida until his early 40s and he had
what we call
friendly a midlife crisis and he gave it
all up and bought a pig farm in Iowa and
became a pig farmer of course there are
those who might say he was just
exchanging one kind of swell for another
but but he did that he did that and it's
the successful pig farm and it's called
southern accents farm that's from his
Florida Tom because he is a southerner
as he says in the letter and he ends it
after four pages of talking about the
book this way thank you so much
underlying for sharing your beloved
Bubba with us I now love her too as I
have known her by another name in
another time and another place which
told me what I needed to know which is
that the more personal and the more
intimate you are in your writing the
more Universal you are that was a
remarkable phenomenon for me to discover
that and so I had no fear when I began
thinking about writing about my father I
just wrote about everything and those of
you who've read the book know that I
wrote about everything I hid absolutely
nothing and I realized that because I
was trying to find my father because I
was trying to understand my father it
wouldn't help to fictionalize anything
those of you who've read enough memoirs
know that there comes a time and
virtually every memoir will you raise
your eyebrow and you say could this
really have happened is this possible
could he have remembered this much
detail or that conversation and you
wondered so i decided i would only put
in any other a little bits of
conversation in here the conversation
that I really remembered and so I did it
because that was how I was going to find
him and if I changed anything I was not
going to come to an understanding of how
I felt about him what he meant to me and
any resolution of how we were with one
another and would remain for the rest of
what I have left of life which I hope is
at least to that 78
so what I want to do right now is to
read certain sections from the book to
give you some idea of how I did it I'll
never forget the moment I sat down to
write you know I've never had writer's
block because i have two anatomical
structures which prevent me from ever
having writer's block and you all have
them they are called buttocks if you put
them on a chair in front of a desk with
paper or in front of a computer it's
amazing what happens you may waste the
first hour typing or writing nonsense
but eventually your book of your essay
is going to start my experience with
people who writers blocks is that they
don't they don't apply those two great
anatomical structures to the chair they
walk around they go to the baseball game
they smoke a cigarette they call a
friend that isn't the way to do it you
just sit down and start going and I sat
down and I found myself thinking about
when it is nowadays that I am closest to
my father and interestingly when I am
closest to my older son and it's that
yearly pilgrimage that we make to that
Cemetery in Queens so I decided that the
introductory sections of this book would
deal with that time the perversity of
inanimate objects we stood there at the
foot of the grave just the two of us
shoulder to shoulder father to son
generation to generation an aura of
memories enveloped us those old and
those more recent those bidden and those
unbidden all alike crowded into that
moment of our lives as they always do
when my elder son and I stand together
in that green sorted place of the Dead
here thousands and more thousands of
closely planted headstones marked the
burial sites of turn-of-the-century
Jewish immigrants
and their descendants true and I were
standing before the grave of my father
now dead some 40 years and yet in some
ways more commanding and more needful
then he had been during his life
hundreds of yards away an occasional
workman could be seen attending to some
cluster of ivy or an unruly growth of
bush but it was too early on that crisp
October morning for anyone else to have
yet arrived except for our quiet
conversation the only sounds
interrupting the verdant stillness where
the chirping of birds in the occasional
roar of a low flying airplane going to a
from Kennedy Airport where my son had
arrived from half a world away less than
an hour earlier in that section of the
entire sprawling metropolis of long
warned or forgotten lives drew and I
were by ourselves we were alone with our
dead Jew has accompanied me here since
he was a small boy in recent years
planning his journeys from the far-off
country where he lives to stand with me
on my yearly pilgrimages to this place
though he never knew any of those whose
memories we come to commune with my
father my mother and rose a baby brother
who died before I was born they have
made their mark on him just as surely as
though he had grown up among them in
that small Bronx apartment of such
emotional turbulence but none of them
has affected his life more than my
father on these visits drew is the
surrogate for all of my children who
knowingly are not accompany me on a
circuitous journey toward an attempt at
understanding that I began long before
any of them were born it is a journey
that can never be completed I am trying
to find the truth of my father and in
the process to find a part of myself
that I've never understood but like the
countless others who've embarked on
similar quests I'm determined to travel
as far as I can toward the ultimate
destination
we visit our dead to keep faith with
them but much more difficult as making
the peace that so many of us have never
achieved it is a kind of peace that can
be found only when we come to terms with
just who it is that they really were and
who it is that we ourselves have become
so much of it because of them my
father's power and the weakness that
nurtured it have accompanied me all the
days of my life I have struggled to be
the unhip to be the opposite of what he
was and in the struggling I have
faltered and fallen many times his
lingering power over me has been the
source of much of my weakness I have
responded to the threat of his weakness
by seeking to find ways to resist it to
be so powerful against it though I am
unassailable by that great portion of
himself that he has left within me and
in the process I have instead become
rather more like him than less I'm
writing this book to help me come to
terms with my father I'm writing this
book to finally make peace with him and
perhaps with myself my father is someone
that I refer to in this book as in the
Latin sweet generous in a class by
himself he managed somehow to heroically
avoid becoming assimilated into this
country you know when we think of
assimilation we think of becoming part
of the country for immigrants we forget
about that other part of assimilation
which is to assimilate into yourself
what this country is the values of this
country for me the greatest thing about
America believe it or not was the
language this remarkable language that
has three times the number of words of
any Western European language that
enables us to be so specific in our
choice of words whether we realize it or
not that there is no mistaking
what we mean when we write unlike
European languages the beauty of which
is paradoxically that there is
interpretation and it depends on how the
word is used in the sentence language to
me the English language was my
liberation it was my way of getting out
of what I'm about to read about that I
described this family that just seemed
not to understand and the epitome of
that family was my father who was
gripped in addition to everything else
by an illness of his spinal cord that
confused me whose diagnosis eluded me
until I was a first-year medical student
I discovered it late one night in the
dormitory on Howard Avenue in New Haven
I described that in this book but that
illness and the way he walked in the way
he moved made even greater the
separation from him and everything that
went on him went on around him in
America memory plays tricks it has its
own plans and it goes its own way
sometimes it with holds key elements in
the story of a life they may never be
divulged or may come to the surface only
when the mind is prepared to accept them
and perhaps that's why no mention of my
father except an obe liquid ease is to
be found in any book I've previously
written so far from deliberate was his
absence from my pages that I was shocked
when it was pointed out to me soon after
how he died was published in 1994 but I
knew immediately what to make of it
unlike any of the others whose devotion
has brought me to this place and this
time my father now dead more than 40
years remains a constant looming
presence in everything I do but an
unresolved one he walks with me through
every day of my life in that unsteady
faltering gate that so embarrassed me
when I was a boy always he's holding
fast to the upper part of my right arm
now and then the uncertain grip of his
hand slips just a bit and he grabs it
more deeply for security and he grabs on
to the cloth of my sleeve and the skin
beneath it is
pinched between his fingertips as though
in the jaws of a clamp and I winced with
pain as his whole Titans I tell him that
he's hurting me he's offended by that
and he lets me know it and rumbling
Yiddish as we make our way together my
father I called him daddy when I was
small because it sounded American and
that's how he wanted it to be so
desperately wanted things to seem is
speaking in the idiosyncratic rhythms of
a self constructed English pronounced in
a way that emanated from no one's lips
but his a particular istic accent that
is better described as having been yet a
shy than Yiddish infiltrated as it was
with a speech mannerisms of the
italian-born garment workers with whom
he toiled in the sweatshops of New
York's garment district I have to stop
for a moment to tell you about Mel
Brooks who once said that his mother who
came from a little town in eastern
europe like my father spoke with an
almost Irish accent and he couldn't
figure it out until one day it hit him
when she came to this country all the
authority figures in Brooklyn where they
lived were Irish cops so she imitated
the way they spokes this little old
Jewish lady spoke with an Irish accent
there was my father speaking out like
half italian half Jewish sometimes you
couldn't tell I've never heard anyone
speak that way either in terms of
pronunciation or sentence structure try
as I may it defies my attempt to imitate
it or reproduce that on the page like
everything else about my father his
speech was one of a kind as paradoxical
as it seems to invoke such a term when
describing a virtually unassimilated
Jewish immigrant who knew nothing about
the wider culture of this or any other
country who was in fact lost in America
Meyer noodleman was sweet generous in a
class by himself but there was nothing
sweet generous about his appearance he
was of average height for his generation
of shtetl Jews which is to say about 5
foot 7 and his head of fine dark hair
formed a widow's peak above a high for
it if there is truly such a thing as a
Jewish nose Meyer Nudelman was its
proprietor
centered on the broad straight nasal
bone that widened at the cartilage its
nostrils flared into a classic Semitic
curve on each side his eyes were deep
brown in color with just a touch of
world-weary sadness they were always
covered with a barely perceptible tier
layer the slightly glistening effect
being one of soulful musing at all they
had seen and were seeing he had a way of
laughing uncontrollably when something
struck him as being particularly funny
which made those soulful eyes fill with
tears as a boy I would sometimes have to
ask him whether he was laughing or
crying which could be very perilous if
the episode was the result of a
facetious barb I had just thrown in his
direction like so many other things
about him his responses to such wise
cracks were unpredictable sometimes he
loved a joke on himself and sometimes he
reacted with outrage Meyers eyes were
among the several physical
characteristics that set him apart from
the rest of our family ours were blue
and every one of us had hair that if not
still blonde was identifiable as having
been that color in youth we were clear
eyed and looked optimistic in spite of
ample reason to be otherwise not only
his eyes and the color of his hair made
Meyers seem different he was as unsure
of his movements as he was unsure of his
place in our family I would later learn
in medical school that a diffused
scarring of the spinal cord resulting
from an infection acquired in his youth
had left him progressively unable to use
his hands or legs in the unthinking
automatic way that other people do his
condition worsened each year I knew him
he had to concentrate his mind on every
step in every movement even when he
brought a fork full of food to his mouth
something of him had retreated to a deep
place within and he showed it by a stoop
in his back and a hunching of his
shoulders it was this posture that I
assumed during the worst of my illness
the opening chapter of this book is a
description of the profound
depression that I lived through 1972
1973 in which I actually had to be
hospitalized I responded so poorly that
in those days when prefrontal lobotomy
was still an option although rarely used
they were seriously not just considering
it but had recommended it at the
institute of living in hartford and at
work took a 27 year old resident
assigned to my case to dig in his heels
and say oh no you won't let's try
electroshock therapy which at that time
was was somewhat at a vogue but they did
and it took 20 treatments so that i
could be here today actually and that's
how the book begins with that
description a proud man reduced to
debility is hypersensitive to any
perceived slight my father demanded not
merely deference but total respect from
his two sons and when he thought it not
to be forthcoming he would lash out in a
ranting deluge of anger that had more of
it of impotent rage than of authority oh
look a word even a suspect intonation
from either of us or some other member
of the family was enough to incite his
wrath by the time of my adolescence my
father had become so disabled by that
seemingly undiagnosable neurologic
disease that he needed help in some of
his daily activities particularly
walking if it was even a bit of snow or
ice on the sidewalks he could make his
way only with great difficulty walking
to the subway station each morning in
order to get to work he would clutch my
arm tightly as we laborious Lee
negotiated the three long blocks at the
end of the day I always waited for him
at the hundred and eighty third Street
Station just beyond the turn styles it
would appear promptly at five forty-five
furious if he didn't see me standing in
my usual place as he approached the
difficult trudged homeward took 15
minutes more or less depending on the
accumulation of snow and ice I had to
take in many other places to my right
arm was his staff I could advance only
slowly because he held me back
I could wander only so far because there
were times when I needed to be available
for him even now I can feel his hand
squeezing my arm I am in his grip still
in the very fabric of my father's power
over me lay his powerlessness and his
need for my power his whole did not
signify strength but weakness his
weakness was his strength I did his
bidding always fearful of being the
agent of his destruction if I did
otherwise always fearful to of the
explosiveness of his wrath and in this
he was my imperious overlord I would
only be free with his death or so I
thought I would be proven wrong with his
death came a new power with far greater
consequences than those I had grown up
with it was the smothering power of
enduring love and though I refused to
face it for decades to come and during
hate I've been able to do nothing that
might permanently free me from either
nor have I been able to do anything that
might free me from my father and his
awful power over me perhaps now I have
begun to see that it is not freedom I
should have been seeking but
understanding now lest you think that
this is a big long lugubrious book I
want to tell you what the Bronx was like
the 1930s and 1940s because a
significant part of this book is devoted
to that era and some of you look to me
like you're old enough if it's not the
Bronx it may have been Milwaukee or it
may have been San Francisco or who knows
where but you'll remember some of this
stuff especially those of you who lived
in a mixed neighborhood as I did I have
to tell you that I had not been there
since I left the age 28 when my father
died and i came back briefly for his
funeral but may last May almost a year
ago now I decided to make a pilgrimage
back to the Bronx it is that precinct in
which I live that police precinct if
you've ever seen Fort Apache that
movie that is the precinct in which Fort
Apache was filmed supposed to be a very
dangerous place I went to my high school
I went to my PS 33 I went to the Fordham
branch of the New York Public Library
librarian asked what I was doing there
this whole white guy I told her this is
where I learned to be an American she
said what's your name and I told her and
she said come with me and she took me to
one of the shells or two of my books
were it's amazing thing I started there
when I was 7 my first book was AB the
caveman and I of course aight that up
and then I started reading everything I
could find in that library like so many
of you I'm sure and like so many kids
growing up at that time there was no
television as you all recall and that's
what we did we we read books and the
amazing thing about that library was it
was still full of kids and they were
black and Hispanic and everything that I
had been told about my neighborhood was
bolide by what I saw in that library
here were kids that their computers they
were writing term papers neighbor
whispering to each other in the corner
and I tried to over here and they were
talking about the same kind of serious
stuff we used to talk about and getting
hushed up by the librarian in exactly
the same way the old men who were
sitting out on the stoop to the houses
weren't Italian in Jewish old man they
were an old Irishman anymore they were
old hispanic guys with an occasional old
african-american guy but it was just
like it had been so that encouraged me
to go to 2314 Morris Avenue where I
lived all those years got there when I
was age three and I rang the doorbell of
apartment where I grew up and in
retrospect everybody said hey are you
out of your bloody mind but I wasn't out
of my mind mrs. Valdez opened the door I
told her who I was she thought about it
for a minute went in and consulted with
her mother and they let me into
apartment a where I as I say was from
the age of three it's amazing nothing
had changed
they had no more dumbwaiter they had
closed off one passageway and made it
slightly different they had been the
only thing that was different was the
apartment was not half the size I
remembered but a third the size I
remembered so I'm encouraged I'm
encouraged about all of it and I
wouldn't know have no hesitation about
going back there tomorrow but I want to
read to you what it was like in those
days let me start with my gang our
building straddle the border between the
completely Catholic Irish and Italian
lower half of the block and the
completely Jewish upper half of the
block I played exclusively with them
until Alfred salemi and I got into a
fistfight with anti-semitic overtones
when I was seven resulting in a
precipitous transfer of my allegiances
from the Catholic rudy's gang to the
predominantly Jewish popeyes gang up the
block twest kids the word gang had no
dark connotations it simply meant that a
large group of boys played together
under the leadership of a particularly
gifted athlete our leaders were Rudolph
speciali always called Rudy special and
Ronald Popeye Eisenberg morris avenue in
daylight hours was a sea of children of
all ages shortly after school let out at
three each afternoon the houses on both
sides of the block discouraged dozens of
energetic noisy boys who quickly joined
together in several age determined
groups and started up the round of those
games now so well remembered by hundreds
of thousands of us who grew up in the
boroughs of New York City in the 1930s
and 1940s stickball punchball johnny on
the pony street hockey on roller skates
baseball against the wall which was our
version of a sport elsewhere called
stoop ball amis marbles to the
unsophisticated skelly territory touch
football chicken fighting or just hung
around
chicken fighting had nothing to do with
chickens it was a challenge of single
combat in which each of the two
gladiators would fold both arms across
his chest and repeatedly throw himself
forcefully against the front of his
opponent while hopping on one leg the
off-balance bumping and banging went on
until one of them fell or had to set his
raised foot on the pavement in order to
stay upright sometimes three or more
boys took part in the contest and the
winner was the last one of them left
hopping I missed Rudy's gang at first
mostly because I had learned so much
from the uncensored conversations I had
heard even when not engaged in games
this group of boys always seem to have
tantalizing things to talk about like
the skim penis of rosemary o'sullivan's
blue Underpants when Frankie by tag
liano caught a glimpse of them as she
lost her balance and fell over while
playing Potsie for the impressive size
of the burgeoning new breasts on Jack
O'Brien's big sister or the rumors that
civiletti the shoemaker had been seen in
the vestibule of 2295 with his hand up
the dress of a giggling mrs. syzmonski
the leggy bleached blonde wife of our
milkman popeyes gang was more interested
in sports movies and radio programs than
an earthiness it was with them that I
began to engage in endless debates about
baseball though I knew very little about
it at first other than the familiar
names of such Yankees as Crosetti
Ruffing Gomez Dickie Ralph and that
newcomer DiMaggio then follow three
paragraphs in which I described how i
learned about sex verbally of course at
the age of nine and how I learned a few
dirty words but we'll skip over those
and tell what it was like in the
apartment our four-room apartment was
located on the first floor of 2314 was
reached by climbing a flight of stairs
leading from the street to a locked
glass door separating the building's
lobby from the outside a key or buzzer
system was required to open the door but
by the time I was ten I had learned to
unlock it with my thumbnail
the windows of our two-bedrooms tanta
aya who was my aunt my maiden aunt and
Bubba and one my parents and the other
Harvey and I slept in different places
at different times either in the bedroom
or in the living room fronted on Morris
Avenue although the view from my parents
bedroom was partially blocked by a large
fire escape the windows of the kitchen
and living room on the other hand faced
on the opposite side of the building
they looked out onto the concrete
pavement of the backyard which was
separated by a low stone wall from the
adjacent lot on which stood the
synagogue called synagogue by my father
and the abandoned house in those first
years of living a 23-14 Morris Avenue
and especially later when the backyard
had been closed in by the construction
of a new apartment house I inadvertently
studied sociology in contemporary
cultural history just by listening to
the conversations and other sounds that
waft 'add unbidden through the open
windows of our apartment into that busy
little enclosure would come an endless
stream of old clothes peddlers street
singers itinerant tradesmen the various
sorts and other representatives of that
entire spectrum of Penny hucksters who
made their precarious livings by working
the backyards of the Bronx in the
decades on either side of World War two
the little courtyard had the acoustic
qualities of vertical sound shoot five
stories high on summer days amplified
words flew in and out of open windows as
though the speaker's intended that their
conversations should reach the most
remote corner of every neighbors rooms
thanks to a constantly bickering couple
on the third floor I hadn't live in my
vocabulary with a goodly store of
old-world maledictions before my eighth
birthday the acrimonious Weinstein and
his acid tongue mrs. lived with a
[ __ ] adult daughter Sophie in a
state of perpetual warfare which made my
own family seemed like an assemblage of
cooing turtle doves
although they were not particularly
innovative in their verbal assaults on
one another their mutuality of I bulging
animus could be depended upon to provide
frequent bursts of the more common
Yiddish execrations in which the dull
but nevertheless shrill sophie was often
a participant being much taken even when
so young with forms that I would later
learn were called alliteration and
parallel ism I was especially fond of
and this is obviously in Yiddish but I'm
did in the kishka zabrak did in the
g'dalien which means like what it sounds
may there be by you are burning in the
intestine and are breaking in the guts
though I heard it often it wasn't until
medical school that I learned that the
elder Weinstein's were wishing a case of
cholera on each other a disease well
known to the Jews of Eastern Europe I
accumulated a vaster of maledictions
like this one although there are
nowadays few opportunities to fling them
at deserving recipients who also happen
to understand Yiddish and so the book
you know goes on and talks about what it
was like living in that family in that
place describes going through high
school after my mother's death when my
father was really left all alone with
his sister-in-law and his mother-in-law
and neither of whom spoke to him
incidentally barely spoke to each other
and then as my father's health gradually
deteriorated and I was applying to
medical school I started medical school
in 1951 so I was applying in 1950 and
those were terrible times it's just as
hard to get into medical school nowadays
but at least it doesn't make any
difference what ethnic group you came
from there were some pretty tight quotas
and I had worked very hard in college I
was determined determined to get out of
New York to go to a medical school
outside of New York and in those days we
used to apply we Jewish kids in the
Bronx to about 35 schools I didn't have
enough ten dollars is to apply to 35
school so I applied to 25 schools which
was still quite a bit more represented
quite a bit more money than I head but
the first school to accept me was
remarkably Hopkins Johns Hopkins of all
places accepted me first I had an
interview at it was on Goldwater its
name of that Island where Goldwater
Memorial Hospital is it was an alumni
interview and five days later I was
admitted and it was very exciting in the
house because we then knew that I was
going to be a doctor obviously I
couldn't go there because we couldn't
afford I couldn't afford to live out of
town and there's a story about that how
I managed to do that eventually but I
have never been able to forget and I
talked about it in this book the way my
Aunt Rose who never married and had a
circle of four or five friends would
also never married described on the
telephone that I had been admitted to
medical school she was speaking to her
friend Becky schiff and she's speaking
in Yiddish and she said so happily and
so proudly I wasn't 10 feet away she
says Shep's law which is my Yiddish name
Shep cyl is our language I and Shep cyl
has been admitted to Johnson's
Thompson's medical school
this this and there are some great
stories better in the book but I must
tell you that I helped her with her
studies when she decided to become a
citizen after being in this country for
half a century and I don't know how they
do it now but in those days they would
give each potential citizen a book to
study American history in American
culture and then they give you a quiz
and if you pass the quiz you could get
your so-called second papers the
declaration of intent was the first
papers five years later you judge second
papers now I was helping her and some of
those pieces of information in the
Bookroom booklet were very specific and
I asked her the standard questions of
the back and I came to the one who was
the president of the Confederacy pretty
tough question but she knew she said
jefferson davis and i asked the next
question which was who was the president
of the union and she said david Dubinsky
who else well so i was going to go to
hopkins if I could somehow get the money
together although it seemed impossible
and that friday night i was on the phone
call on the phone with my friend
leibowitz we'd only gotten a phone a
couple of years before otherwise we used
to get down the corner drugstore and
stick a nickel and I'm sure some of you
did the same and I'm talking to
Leibovitz on the phone and he says did
you apply to Yale I looked down my list
I couldn't remember where I'd applied
yeah yeah yeah I applied to Yale but did
you know they don't have exams exams it
was friday evening and monday morning
you could do this kind of thing in those
days i called the yale admissions office
and I said lying through my teeth I said
you know I was accepted to obvious but I
really want to go to Yale yeah that's
the place I want to go can I have an
interview well things were blacks are
then they said sure show up on Wednesday
be here at eleven or something like this
or it noon so I got on the train what is
now called the metro-north yield New
York New Haven and Hartford railroad i
plunked down four dollars and
thirty-five cents for a round-trip
ticket I got off in New Haven and I
walked
to the medical school and I had two
interviews and at the end of the second
interview they invited me to tea tea
imagine such a thing t he walked me down
this long corridor and that this room is
now gone it was a faculty lounge a
beautifully carpeted faculty lounge and
faculty wise every afternoon at four
o'clock serve tea and there were these
handsome young men with white buck shoes
and he's beautiful young women from the
Yale nursing school and the atmosphere
was so subdued and and so quiet and
genteel and I thought huh I don't belong
in a place like this which is exactly
why I want to go here so week later I
got my acceptance and I lived happily
ever after at least in the reference to
the yale medical school I lived happily
ever after but it was the tea and the no
exams that got me here otherwise I'd be
giving this talk Baltimore something
somewhere so I tell the story of my
father's last illness and I tell the
story of the residency program at the
Yale New Haven Hospital in those days
where there was a pyramid they chose 13
of us the first year as interns and
every year they fired a few or worse yet
they made them go into gynecology
orthopedics and bit by bit they would
filter us out and in the wood to who
ended up at the end being the chief
residents in what was called general and
cardiovascular surgery and lo and behold
on my birthday which was December eighth
nineteen fifty-eight my 28th birthday I
was notified that i was one of the two
people who had been chosen chief
resident my father was in the hospital
and I waited till Wednesday when I had
the evening off and I had a car by that
I had had a fellowship a research
fellowship were three thousand dollars
so i took 1200 of it and bought a
second-hand car and I'd had that for
three years at that point I drove down
New York and I visited my father
manav here and I told him that this
culmination of everything that we had
wished for and everything that we had
worked for had come true I was going to
be chief resident in this very waspy
place that he had never heard of ten
years earlier as a matter of fact well
he everybody heard of Harvard yeah we
knew that Harvard was a place where
Roosevelt's sons had gone to school and
we knew that Harvard and Yale had a crew
race on the Thames River in New London
every year because my grandmother used
to have a farm near there when she was
younger and that's what we knew about
Harvard and Yale until I went there to
medical school that's how completely out
of phase we were with the surrounding
culture and hair I was going to be chief
resident and it was it was a wonderful
moment for the two of us it was a
Wednesday and I went back to the
hospital was on duty friday evening and
got a phone call from the urology
resident he was on the urology service
because one of the complications of his
illness was urological and he told me
they'd found him dead in bed just two
days after I had been able to tell him
this so I tell that story as though it
resolves something as though are coming
together at that time had somehow been
accompanied while he lived and after his
death I have been consumed with a futile
effort of trying to rid myself of meijer
noodleman incidentally I tell the story
of the name change which still
fascinates me some of my cousins had
invented this name really invented it
out of whole cloth new land this was the
new country and we adopted it when I was
a senior in high school and I tell all
of the complex reasons including I have
to admit as I do here shame that I
decided to change that name to what our
cousins had done so let me start again
on this afterward for too many years
while he lived in
after his death I've been consumed with
a futile effort of trying to rid myself
of meijer noodleman he wanted to change
his name to but that would have defeated
one of our main purposes in changing
hours which was to separate ourselves
from him and what to us in our
adolescent thinking he represented still
during much of the attempted escape I've
sought to come to terms with my father
even stumbling and falling along the way
weakened and made frail my shoulders
stooped by an illness whose emotional
torment succeeded in mimicking his
physical ones I have seemed in those
dreadful hours to become him at the
worst of times fearful thoughts have had
to be burned out of my brain with great
jolts of electric current I required
much help I will never know the cost of
being Myers son men when midway in life
circuitous journey I found myself
entrapped within those dark and tangled
woods I should not have blamed him for
my loss of direction my father was
without a compass and he too had missed
his path the choices I had made and the
directions i had taken to lead me into
the morass were mine alone the
blundering attempts to loose myself from
the thickets were also mine but unlike
him I did at last find my way out even
my bad choices were not enough to
prevent my ultimate choice which was to
resume the voyage and naked in peace as
child in the synagogue on Yom Kippur I
would stand alongside my father in
tremulous awe as we in tone the ancient
formula before the heavenly decision is
made as to who shall be at peace and who
shall be tormented but penitence prayer
and good deeds can avert the severity of
decree the Hebrew word translated in the
prayer book as penitence is chuva whose
literal meaning is returned I have owed
Myra noodleman recompense for the
ravages inflicted on his years and font
from my inability to perceive his
unhappiness
it is by returning to memory and to my
father that I have sought to comprehend
my own severe decree against myself the
guilt and the sickness whose ravages are
not to be forgotten my quest has been to
perceive what he really was
understanding has come but slowly it has
taken me overly long to reach the stage
of the journey when I'm finally able to
look back and see so much of him with
full awareness I have sought to be what
he could not be but I have not been able
to deafen myself through the years to
the siren call of its opposite dark and
feeling seduction luring me to make
myself what he was and it has sometimes
unmanned me and seeking to escape him I
have drawn closer and now at last I know
that the closeness can be good I've been
trying to find his way in America for
him and for me there is no end to it and
that's the end of the book and that's
the end of I wanted what I wanted to
talk to you about this afternoon and I'm
up for grabs if anybody wants to come in
or ask any questions here we are
dr. sherwin newland his author of lost
in America it's published by Knopf a
division of Random House visit Random
House calm / Knopf for more information